- They call this stretch
of the North Shore
the Seven Mile Miracle.
There is a world-class surf
break every 100 or so yards.
We rescue up to a thousand people a year.
Definitely one of the most dangerous
stretches of beaches in the world.
My name is Tau Hannemann
and I've been a lifeguard for 14 years
here on the North Shore.
I work here at Ehukai Beach Park.
It's the home of the surf
break Banzai Pipeline,
which is a very dangerous wave
that breaks in very shallow water.
It's such a critical wave
that if you fall down,
the chances of getting injured,
of hitting the reef is very high.
Even when it's really small,
we have very strong, powerful rip currents.
It's very easy to get swept
out in the rip current
and not be able to make it back to shore.
Just yesterday, the lifeguards
made about 20 rescues.
Knowing that the possibility
of drowning is very real,
you know, especially in
large surf, we all train.
My training consists of
running the beach or swimming
anything basically in my area.
We do mock rescues.
If the surf is big, I'll
tell one of my partners,
“hey, go out and get pounded in the surf.
“I’ll come get you with the rescue tube.”
So he'll go out and, you know,
he's taking waves on the head
and we'll see how fast we can get to him.
Whatever the ocean's going to do,
if someone needs help and you
have to go get that person,
you gotta be ready to do that.
You're putting yourself
in a very risky situation,
but knowing that your
partner has your back,
it builds a strong sense of camaraderie.
We have a good morale between us all.
We do this job for the love of the job.
Basically, if you can save
another person's life,
it's very rewarding, for sure.